social impact business are profitable
market-based solutions that address
social needs of low-income populations
in different emerging markets they have
the explicit intention to cause social
impact so the core business is tied to
socially impact and they not only offer
opportunities of employment but mainly
offer products and services that address
the needs of low-income population in
areas such as financial services house
education housing and very important
they need or they should have the
capacity to scale you because as social
problems are very big
we need them to scale
this is a very interesting question in
fact this is a big debate even in the
NGO space so everyone is trying to
measure social impact in the impact
investing field the most common and more
adopted methodology is the gears the
global impact investing rating system a
system that was developed by Jim the
global impact investing Network which is
very good because it's global you can
have a standard so you can compare
businesses from different markets but it
has some limitations the good thing is
they are very open to improvements so
businesses and funds and accelerators
are helping them to improve and this is
a very good standard to be use it it's
very disseminated in Brazil some
businesses have their own indicators
according to their social mission but
the big challenge when you talk about
measuring social impact is when you
think about early-stage business when
entrepreneurs are so busy trying to make
their business be successful that they
don't have time to seek for measurement
so what we really need is a kind of
measurement that is both time and cost
effective to be adopted
also by early-stage entrepreneurs